台灣藝人許效舜
他痛風痛了三十多年
可以說是活生生的
痛風代表
有一次他到澳門吃明蝦
隔天啊
痛風發作
腳痛到站都站不起來了
吃止痛藥也沒有用
最後只能坐輪椅
搭飛機回台灣
在醫院裡住了
整整九天才出院
想避免痛風復發嗎
來喝這一杯OO
降低痛風風險
等一下馬上告訴你
胡乃文開講囉
我是你的老朋友 胡醫師
這一集要和你分享
喝1杯飲料 降4成痛風的風險
痛風發作 1穴位吃2水果止痛
1碗台灣小吃 降尿酸三高
不吃海鮮也痛風？
喝1杯降4成痛風風險
台灣有痛風的人口
接近百萬
這數字可真是嚇人啊
想預防痛風
來每天喝一杯牛奶
新英格蘭醫學期刊指出
每天喝乳製品的人
得到痛風的機會
能夠降低百分之
44%
但是提醒你
牛奶不要喝太冰的喔
牛奶的乳清蛋白
能讓尿酸溶解順利的排出
而它的酪蛋白呢
加速乳酸排泄
間接的讓
尿酸也跟著排出去了
誒 有粉絲問我
胡醫師啊
我不喝牛奶怎麼辦
沒關係 不喝牛奶的人
你吃無糖的優格
哎 也是可以的
痛風是中年人
才會得的病嗎
不是
現在甚至連國小生
都得到痛風了
是真的嗎 太離譜了
是真的 一位八歲的小男生
經常吃滷肉飯
把自己養得是白白胖胖的
有一天走路 突然跛腳了
一檢查發現
竟然是痛風發作
還合併其他的慢性病
真的 讓人是捏一大把冷汗啊
痛風不只是會找上
愛吃大魚大肉喝酒
或肥胖的男性
這兩種人也得要注意喔
愛喝含糖飲料的人
停經之後的女性
小編啊
你每天都在喝飲料
你要給我注意喔
好喔 醫師
我會從一個禮拜
喝7杯飲料
改成6杯半
一半分給同事
哇
少喝點
小編啊 你知道嗎
每天喝500cc含糖飲料的人
含糖飲料裡的
高果糖玉米糖漿
會阻礙尿酸的排出
停經以後還沒有喔 你沒有
停經以後的女性
因為雌激素的下降
尿酸代謝就變慢了
痛風風險
也會大幅的增加喔
痛風不好好治療
會面臨什麼問題
洗腎 洗腰子啊
尿酸太多會沉積在關節
讓你腫得難受 痛到抓狂
時間久了 腎臟也開始受損
萬一更嚴重的話
很可能就要
洗腎了
那個時候傷身花錢
又花很多的時間
是不是得不償失啊
半夜痛風發作？
1穴止痛補腎
用這兩招快速消除痛風
第一招
你先用毛巾包裹著冰塊
敷在腫的地方來止痛
第二招 按1個穴
按什麼呢
太溪穴
太溪穴可厲害了
急性痛風
你按這個穴位
它能夠緩解疼痛
慢性期來按太溪穴 能夠補腎
太溪穴在哪個地方啊
在內踝尖和後頭的
阿基里斯腱之間的
那個凹陷的洞洞裡面
那個就是
你現在就可以邊按邊聽我
慢慢的跟你道來
太溪穴不只是能夠止痛
它的功效還真是不少
能調整腎氣虛
導致的尿酸代謝失衡
它是腎經的非常大的大穴
你是屬於痛風
尿酸過高的人
平時就多按揉這個穴位
它能從根本調整腎氣
將毒素排出體外
讓痛風不再半夜和你糾纏
2水果止關節腫痛
喝豆漿會引起痛風？
痛風的人
你是不是會擔心喝了豆漿
吃了豆干會讓痛風更嚴重
別擔心
其實是在急性期的時候
不能吃豆製品
在慢性期
豆腐 豆干 豆漿
這些都還可以正常吃
來 我來教你
急性慢性痛風飲食怎麼吃
讓你快快遠離痛風
先說第一部份
急性期
當你關節痛得很厲害
痛風發作時候
來 吃兩種水果
1 櫻桃 2 藍莓
櫻桃和藍莓啊
有植化素和多酚
能減少尿酸結晶的形成
抗發炎
對於關節疼痛
特別有幫助
研究發現
每天吃10到12顆櫻桃
或者是一小碗的藍莓
大概是女生的拳頭
這麼大小的一份
能夠減少痛風
反覆發作的風險
但不是吃越多越好啊
吃多了反而糖份太高了
那急性期不能吃哪些食物
四類食物先暫停
1.肉類
像紅肉
例如牛肉 羊肉 豬的紅肉
2.海鮮 3.酒類
4.高普林的食物
魚皮 小魚乾 內臟
還有很濃的火鍋湯
雞精這些湯
還有就是
這些蔬菜
豆苗 豆芽 蘆筍 香菇 紫菜
也先不要吃
這些食材
它的核酸的含量比較高
容易提高尿酸
再來講慢性期
你的飲食
可以慢慢回到正常
不過急性期
不能吃的食物
還是不要多吃哦
吃白肉 魚 蛋 豆製品
但是要記得
油炸的豆類還是不要吃
甜食 酒類 含糖飲料都要少碰
平常你喜歡辣粉 胡椒粉
撒好撒滿的
愛吃重口味的
你把口味調得淡一些
減輕腎臟的負擔
最後喝水也很重要
多喝水可以降尿酸嗎
可以
多喝水能夠增加尿量
加速尿酸的排出
降低尿酸在關節裡沉積的風險
有助於控制痛風
1碗小吃超神奇
降尿酸三高
中醫治痛風
不但能把尿酸降下來
還會解決痛風
背後真正的問題
痛風是脾腎出了狀況
痰濕堆積在體內
經絡不通
關節就痛得受不了
想讓痛風不復發
推薦你喝台灣小吃
四神湯
四神湯它有5個很棒的功效
1.健脾利濕
2.通經活絡
3.降尿酸
4.健脾胃
5.降三高
哇 真好
四神湯它的配方很簡單
茯苓 芡實 蓮子 山藥
台灣賣四神湯的店家
都會加個薏仁
薏仁就是這一碗湯的靈魂
神農本草經記載
薏仁能治肌肉僵硬
風濕痹痛
長期喝能輕身健體
增強力氣
我有一個病人
78歲老太太
同時有痛風 高血糖 高血壓
我建議他每天喝四神湯
兩年之後痛風不再發作
血糖 血壓都穩定
生活品質大大提升
你知道嗎
他到了90多歲
還能夠坐公共汽車來看我
還有一位
海外的觀眾和我分享
他因為血糖太高
整天都昏昏沉沉
人很不舒服
喝了一週的四神湯之後
他一直降不下來的
那個血糖
竟然降下來了
更奇蹟的是
血壓也降了
人也清爽有精神多了
真是非常的棒吧
如果家裡有三高的人
你可以每週喝兩三次 四神湯
幫你控制血糖 血壓
甚至小孩喝了還能養脾胃 顧腎臟
有一個粉絲
很可愛留言問我
四神湯裡面大部份
都是豬小腸 豬肚
痛風的人
不是不能吃動物內臟嗎
這不是相抵觸了嗎
沒錯 台灣的小吃店賣四神湯
都會加豬腸 豬肚
但是呢
你是痛風的候選人的話
那就還是自己煮四神湯
別買那樣子的現成
煮了豬腸豬肚的四神湯好吧
腿紅腫痛未必是痛風
辨證施治才對證哦
之前我看過一個病人
這個病腿又紅又腫痛得要命
去醫院看了
醫生一直把他當痛風來治療
治了幾個星期都沒治好
而且還痛得不行
最後還是來找到我
我一看就說
嗯 這不是啊
這是蜂窩性組織炎
所以要注意啊
蜂窩性組織炎跟痛風
有一點點相似
痛風是長在關節上面為主
而蜂窩性組織炎
常常是皮膚發了炎了
細菌啊等等這些
經過組織
肌肉的組織而往上走
成為一整條或者一整片的
這紅腫熱痛
因為痛風跟蜂窩性組織炎
看起來很像
因此這個醫生他的第一印象
認為這個紅腫熱痛就是痛風
可是蜂窩性組織炎它是感染
要用抗感染的治療
錯治就會拖病情對不對
所以別以為痛風老毛病又來了
然後自己就判斷了
或者跟醫生就講
我這是痛風了
我們學中醫的人看這些東西
都得要好好的辨證
到底它是屬於什麼樣的問題
對症才會治療有效
親愛的粉絲們
我們已經開啟會員頻道了
如果你認同我推廣中醫
照顧自己健康的理念
歡迎每月小額支持
只要花兩杯咖啡的錢喔
或成為VIP贊助者
有你同行
我們才能走得更遠
真心感謝你哦